من أجل جعل أمريكا رائعة
ومجيدة مرة أخرى ، أعلن الليلة عن
ترشيحي لمنصب رئيس الولايات
المتحدة ،
حسنًا ،
شكرًا لك
الكثير من الأصدقاء والعائلة
الرائعين هنا الليلة ، إنه شيء جميل
، بعض الناس يقولون كيف تتحدث
أمام الكثير من الناس جميعًا.  الوقت الذي
يكون فيه الحب في الغرفة أمرًا
سهلاً حقًا إذا كنت تريد أن تعرف
أنه
يجب عليك تجربته معًا في وقت ما ،
سنواجه أكثر
القوى فسادًا والمصالح الراسخة التي
يمكن تخيلها في بلدنا في
حالة مروعة نحن في ورطة كبيرة
هذه ليست مهمة سياسي أو
مرشح تقليدي ، هذه مهمة
لحركة عظيمة تجسد
شجاعة الثقة وروح
الشعب الأمريكي ، هذه حركة ليست
لفرد واحد إذا كان هناك عمل
لعشرات  الملايين من الأشخاص الفخورين الذين يعملون
معًا من جميع أنحاء الأرض
ومن جميع مناحي الحياة ، صغارًا وكبارًا
، أبيض وأسود ، من أصل إسباني وآسيوي ،
جمعنا العديد منهم  لها
للمرة الأولى